hello this is Justin from the chess
website and today I'm going to be
talking about how to counter the laan
Gambit so the lafi and Gambit is pretty
unique because typically with the black
pieces black doesn't really have many
Gambit options since blacks are move
behind they they want to just catch up
and get a position um but with the laan
Gambit it's a very bold choice and black
tries to make the game very interesting
right away so after E4 E5 and then
Knights F3 very standard stuff we're
attacking this E5 pawn and black just
makes it a complete mess by playing the
move
F5 so F5 is a Gambit in two ways
actually because we can take on F5 or we
could take on E5 and both are good um
but I think the simplest
approach is just to play Knight 6 E5
because that was our idea like that's
what we wanted to do and black didn't
stop it so why not why not just take
that pawn and after knight6
E5 this comes with a pretty serious
threat because black has moved this F
Pawn they have weakened this diagonal
and that's very important that's a huge
thing to notice that's why moving your F
Pawn is generally a bad thing because
now after a move say like f takes E4 we
have Queen's H5 check and there's no
good way to block this check if the king
moves forward Queen to F7 would be very
bad news and the computer actually gives
Maiden 12 from this position
insane but after a move like G6 it seems
like Black's kind of holding for the
moment but we have this killer
shot Knight takes
G6 sacrificing the
Knight and
now it looks like this Knight is hanging
but there's actually nothing that black
can do because H6
G6 uncovers this attack on The Rook so
in this position this Pawn is pinned and
this Knight actually isn't really being
sacrificed um because taking on G6 would
just lose material for black black can
try and move like Knight to F6 getting a
little fancy where move like Knight 6 h8
would not work because although this is
discovered check black can just take the
piece that is checking his King and
black gives up a lot of material doing
very very
well so after Knight takes G6 um Knight
to F6 if we just slide Our Queen back we
still have this pin on on the H file and
we just snagged a free Pawn this king is
going to be forever weak um because
black has lost their f and g pawns so
white is doing very very well here and
should have no problems winning the game
from
here so ft E4 is just not a great idea
black has to deal with this queen to H5
threat and there's going to be two main
ways that the black can try to deal with
this first is uh Queen to F6 Queen to F6
looks a little odd it doesn't really
seem like it defends against Queen H5 um
at first but the idea is after Queen H5
G6 here and this queen does a great job
of Defending um both G6 and The Rook on
h8 so after move like Knight 6 G6 I
could even take back with the pawn where
the queen is now protecting that Rook on
h8 so after Queen to F6 Queen H5 is
actually really bad because after G6 um
not only did Black deal with our threat
but Black's creating threats of his own
they're threatening this queen on H5 and
the Knights on E5 so black is going to
be winning in this
position so after Queen F6 um we have to
be a little careful we can't you know
just do queen H5 against everything we
need to um pay attention to their moves
and in response to this and in response
to most gambits or um really kind of
offbeat tricky um openings we just want
to focus on the opening principles so
here the best move for white here is
just to play D4 just get as much of the
center as we can and that opens up this
line for the bishop to develop in the
future um just a good principled move so
we're not afraid of losing this
Pawn on e4 um because well we just
traded pawns right we took on E5 they
took on e4 a pawn for a pawn um and
after this move we actually have a
bishop to C4 which is very very strong
because there's nothing that black can
do to stop us from getting to this very
weak and very important F7 Square so a
move like Bishop F7 um stop our opponent
from ever
castling is a huge threat here and black
doesn't have a clear way to deal with it
also Knight to F7 trapping The Rook is
also good black is just in a world of
hurt so they can't take on e4 just yet
and instead of doing that they're going
to play D6 first so the idea is that
this Knight is going to get kicked out
of this beautiful square and then once
it Retreats once it goes back somewhere
um like F3
um then a move like Bishop C4 just
doesn't have as much sting to it so
after D6 um we have a few choices for
where to retreat this Knight but we
actually don't want to go to D3 or F3
because black is going to play F6 E4
next and that's just going to waste
another Tempo moving that Knight so
instead of D3 or F3 we want to go to C4
where after this move the Knight is not
being attacked
so after F takes E4 again opening
principles very important we just
develop a piece with Tempo again
attacking that pawn on e4 and it's not
so easy for black to defend it because
black would love to play Move Like
Knights F6 but that's not exactly
possible because that Queen is there um
kind of in a weird position where it's
not really happy and we can gain a lot
of time by attacking it
so after Knight C3 um black could play a
move like Bishop to F5 um this is
possible but we would just play a simple
move like Knight to E3 white is doing
very very well here um we can take this
if we ever want to or we can bring our
other Knight to D5 and create some
problems where the queen can't
necessarily defend C7 and F5 at the same
time so after Knight to E3 um a move
move like it doesn't really matter what
black does um white is just going to be
fine you don't even have to do anything
that special you could just develop your
pieces in Castle either way there's
really no way to go wrong here as long
as you're developing your
pieces um so after Knight C3 the best
move and the most challenging move is
Queen to
G6 so this move is a little bit annoying
because it clears the square for the
knights and it defends here and it also
attacks G2 so G2 is defended but this is
still a little uncomfortable because we
would love to develop this bishop
someday we would love to play Bishop E2
and you know um continue developing our
pieces and threaten Bishop H5 um but
Bishop B2 is just not a good idea Queen
takes
G2 so it's a little bit
uncomfortable and this p forward is kind
of annoying if we let it sit there for
too long it's going to start causing
problems for us it's going to cramp her
position a little bit so after Queen to
G6 the best reply is to play
F3 now this might be a little
counterintuitive because maybe um you
see this Pawn as being weak but because
black hasn't developed any of their
pieces we want to open up the position
and this move definitely opens up the
position
because they can't really do a move like
saying hit to F6 CU we just take on
e4 and after this uh we're doing very
very well move like Knight 6 E4 we would
just play Bishop D3 developing with
Tempo again um and we're in great great
shape we can Castle whenever we want um
and it's important to know after Queen
leg G2 we always have Bishop takes E4
covering that Rook on H1
so
[Music]
um black can't just leave that pawn they
have to take on F3 and after this move
we're going to take back with the queen
um the queen is pretty well placed here
um it's not so easy for black to kind of
kick it around because a move like
Bishop G4 um anytime our opponent makes
a move we want to pay attention to the
squares that are now undefended and if
we look at that this B7 Square where um
kind of shines through as as a very weak
pawn and Black's position just falls
apart very
quickly so after Queen takes F3 um black
just keeps developing Bishop D3 um we're
kind of deep into this line right here
but I wanted to show one more idea after
a move like Queen G4 if black tries to
trade the Queens it's important that we
know what to do so when ever there is a
queen trade in the position doesn't
matter what opening what situation
whenever there's a queen trade the
number one thing to look at is King
safety so here whose King do you think
is
safer so White's King is actually safer
here because we're one move away from
castling and Black's King is two moves
away from castling so we have that
slight Edge there and because of that we
don't want a
castle so or sorry we don't want to
trade Queens um and since we don't want
to trade Queens
um we're going to play a move like Queen
E3 check or queen F2 we just don't want
to trade Queens so um we want to keep
the Queens on the board with a move like
this where the Queens are no longer
seeing each other and castles is coming
next move and again our development is
just incredible here um this is a lovely
position to have with quates
and really we just have no problems
whatsoever so that was after Queen F6
we're just going to play D4 and really
just develop our pieces maybe play F3
later after they take on
e4 so let's look at Knight to F6 this is
a different way to deal with Queen H5 a
little bit more obvious because now
Queen H5 they would just take it but
after this move um I think the the moves
for white are a little bit more simple
because after this move we can just play
Bishop to C4 and again I kind of hinted
at this earlier this F7 square is
incredibly weak and if we can get either
the Knight or the bishop to those
squares Black's going to be in some very
serious
trouble so after Bishop
C4 black
doesn't have a lot of options um if they
try to play a move like D5 to stop this
connection we could just take it like
that's just a free pawn and not only
that like they can't play Knight 6 D5
because of this threat right that Knight
was doing something it went to F6 to
cover H5 and now it's no longer covering
H5 so we have the same idea of um Queen
H5 check followed by Knight 6 G6 six so
um that's just a clean very very clean
and Free Pawn so here not only are we up
two pawns but they're also two Central
pawns they're two powerful pawns so it
doesn't really matter what black does we
could just play D4 we could Castle next
like black has absolutely nothing uh for
the two pawns they've lost and uh we're
just going to play Knight C3 E1 like
it's just a beautiful position because
we have better control of the center
because we have two extra Pawns in the
center so D5 really isn't anything
special we can just take that pawn and
black is in a really unfortunate
situation so in this position Queen to
E7 is a better try from black and after
Queen to
E7 we're just going to play D4 again we
saw this idea with Queen to F6 they
attack our Knight and we just protect it
with D4 also just a great move in
general um staking our claim in the
center and getting ready to develop our
other
pieces so after
D4
um black can do a few things here um but
we'll just look at D6 this is a pretty
common idea um to kick out this Knight
and Black's idea is okay well after you
go Knight to F7 I'm going to take on e4
which comes with check and then if you
just block it I am going to play
D5 and now I'm blocking the connection
between this bishop and the Knight and
that's a problem like that that's a very
serious problem because
um if you just move the bishop somewhere
they're going to trade queens and then
take the knights that's no good um and
then if you take on h8 um they're just
going to going to take this bishop and
this Knight is trapped on h8 so although
you are temporarily of material um black
is going to win that material back in
the long
run so Queen E2 here is not a good idea
so here it's kind of tricky and
counterintuitive the best move in the
position is just to play King to
F1 so try to think for a minute what's
the difference between King F1 and queen
to E2
so let's see if black plays the same
idea right they want to play
D5
here there is a slight
difference we could just play Bishop to
D3 and after Bishop to D3 we're
attacking this queen and they don't have
a way of solving this with check so in
the last line in this position they
played Queen takes E2
and then we took back but now it's no
longer possible and after Bishop to
D3 the queen just has to retreat and
then we can take this rook and um we're
just up a full Rook like this Knight is
trapped again they'll probably be able
to win it but that's going to take a lot
of time and we're still going to be up
material so this is an even better
version um this King F1 move is just a
little subtle difference but it makes a
huge huge just change in the evaluation
of the position um so King to F1 here if
we do a little problem solving is
actually going to be the best move
because we have Bishop D3 to get out of
uh this D5 um
Counterattack so um just to recap um
against the Lavan Gambit we're just
going to take on E5 because they're not
protecting that pawn and after this move
um black needs to deal with Queen Queen
H5 so they're either going to play Queen
to F6 or Knight to F6 if they play
Knight to F6 um we just play Bishop C4
and that causes an issue with Knight to
F7 coming and then if um they play Queen
to F6 we're just going to play D4 and
develop naturally and maybe at the right
time play
F3 all right um that is it let me know
down below if you have any questions and
I'll see you in the next one